- I love when Kim Kardashian
messages me in the middle
of filming a video with Buzzfeed.
- Wow, it's okay Kim
Kardashian never messaged me,
but she will after this makeover.
- She'll probably block
you after this makeover.
(pop music)
- Guys these past few
weeks have been crazy.
I recently did a video where
I tried to get more Instagram
followers and I actually
ended up getting a bunch
of Instagram followers.
Oh my god guys!
I got 10,000 followers!
I've been having so
much fun with Instagram,
posting stories and pictures.
But I still haven't mastered it.
I'll feel pretty confident
on my Instagram game
once I get to a million followers.
And currently I have about,
well over 900,000 to go.
But it's okay cause I got a plan.
So heres what I'm thinking,
most big Instagrammers are out in LA.
So I'm going to LA baby.
So the plan was to fly to LA
and get some help from James Charles
who has almost five million
followers on Instagram.
And takes incredible pictures.
I still can't believe
he agreed to do this.
- Hi sisters.
- I got him in the video
cause he slid into my dms. So.
- Wow you're exposing me this early on.
You slip back into mine
though, you did reply.
- I thought it was just
like being friendly.
I didn't know that was like-
- Is this not our first date?
(popping sound)
- What are we doing today?
- We need to give you a makeover.
- Why?
- Your Instagram kinda sucks.
- What?
- [James] I'm going to Miami bitch.
(laughs)
My new haircut, hashtag
I'm sexy and I know it.
- I feel like I didn't
I didn't write those.
- This feels like a vine,
but like a really bad vine.
- Eric come on you need to
focus on studying that's it.
No more breaks,
okay one more snack break.
Alright come on, come on.
Shit now I'm thirsty.
- Your eyebrows are not
touching anymore which is
really great.
(laughter)
This 21 picture is really cute,
although that should have been
me instead of your girlfriend
but we can let that slide.
This one's a pretty decent one
but once again shoulda been me.
I'm definitely that
flexible, we can do that.
(chuckles)
I think overall your old
Instagram game was horrible.
But everybody's was in like 2013.
I feel like we definitely
need a wardrobe change.
You wear a lot of V necks,
like a lot of V necks.
There's like chest hair
showing in every picture.
- So what's the game plan?
- I think we have to go shopping.
(french music)
So for our first official look for today,
I really wanna put Eric in a
night out fitted tailored suit
type of look.
For the pants you want
the nice skinny fit pair
of black dress pants.
For me personally I hate slim fit pants,
i definitely like pants that
have a good shape to them
and these pants kinda got a
little more narrow at the ankle
which gives a nice shape to the leg.
And we finish off the entire
look with a good and fresh
Chelsea boot.
We also added a bow tie as well,
which I definitely prefer
over a regular long tie.
I just feel like its much, much cuter.
More trendy, more hipster,
and more like New York City
boy on the go.
- But the reason James
found me a new outfit
in the first place was to
help me with my Instagram.
So we took this stylish picture.
I asked him to post it on his Instagram,
he didn't reply.
So I posted it on my own page
and I gained.
I gained no followers.
Literally I got no followers.
And I'm broke because I spent
over 300 dollars on the suit
and a bunch of money to fly to LA.
And after 24 hours of
shopping with James Charles
I'm still wearing a V neck
and my chest hair is still showing.
You know what?
Nobody made it on social
media after 24 hours.
You gotta work, you gotta be persistent.
So I'm not gonna give up.
I'm gonna keep making videos
until I hit a million followers
so lets go find some more help.
(french music)
Let me know who you think
I should reach out to next.